[Music]
let not these reflections
oppress you i shall live without honor
and be nobody anywhere
for if lack of honor is an evil you
cannot be an evil through the
instrumentality of some other
person any more than you can be in shame
it is not your business is it to get
office or to be invited to a dinner
party
certainly not how then can this be any
longer a lack of honor
and how is it that you will be nobody
anywhere
when you ought to be somebody only in
those things which are under your
control
wherein you are privileged to be a man
of the very greatest honor
but your friends will be without
assistance what do you mean by being
without assistance
they will not have paltry coin from you
and you will not make them roman
citizens
well who told you that these are some of
the matters under our control and not
rather things which others do
and who is able to give another what he
does not himself have
get money then says some friend in order
that we too may have it
if i can get money and at the same time
keep myself self-respecting and faithful
and high-minded show me the way and i
will get it
but if you require me to lose the good
things that belong to me
in order that you may acquire the things
that are not good
you can see for yourselves how unfair
and inconsiderate you are
and which do you really prefer money or
a faithful and self-respecting friend
help me therefore rather to this end and
do not require me to do these things
which will make me
lose these qualities but my country says
he so far as lies in me with
will be without assistance again i ask
what kind of assistance do you mean
it will not have logias or baths of your
providing
and what does that signify for neither
does it have shoes provided by the
blacksmith
nor has it arms provided by the cobbler
but it is sufficient if each man fulfill
his own proper function
and have you secured for it another
faithful and self-respecting citizen
would you not be doing it any good yes
very well and then you also would not be
useless to it
what place then shall i have in the
state says he
whatever place you can have and at the
same time maintain the man of fidelity
and self-respect that is in you
but if through your desire to help the
state you lose these qualities
of what good would you become to it when
in the end
you turned out to be shameless and
unfaithful
in this long chapter epictetus analyzes
and exposes some of the errors in in
thinking
involved in a worry or a concern that
many of us experience
at certain points in our existence some
people even
on a daily basis and that is the
fear or the worry of as he puts it being
nobody anywhere the the greek for that
is uh udais nobody no person
udamu in in no place and this really is
something that many of us are concerned
with even those
who feel like we're successful like
we're you know we have external
accomplishments
um those who have a you know big digital
footprint those who've
you know brought about an important deal
those who can point to their wonderful
family we can we can go down the line
about
all these sorts of measures that people
use
and a lot of people still feel like
unless i'm constantly producing unless
i'm i'm doing things that bring me to
people's notice
i'm nobody it's it's a deep fear that
many people have and epictetus councils
don't let these these thoughts or
concerns the
greek for that is dia logismoy these
you know these logis moy which are
thoughts or or things that we say to
ourselves the dia is an intensification
these days we talk sometimes in
therapeutic instances about negative
self-talk
this is exactly what he is
pointing towards so don't let these
dialogues moy
oppress you and what are they i'm going
to be without honor
atimos lacking honor and
um i'll be nobody anywhere i'll be
nobody nowhere quite literally
so he says well let's analyze this let's
think this through
if lack of honor ah timia and he's gonna
change the terms here
from timia which means sort of the the
honor that other people
show us the the regard the celebrity
even that that people have the fame
he's going to change that eventually to
talking in terms of being
axios which here in the translation is
still rendered
as honor but really has to do with being
worthy
or or having value we conflate the two
of these quite easily
other people telling us that we're a
great guy or you know an important
person
or that were you know instrumental to
the company
or instrumental to the institution with
really having genuine value and from a
stoic perspective
it's important to be able to distinguish
these apart from each other so
going back to this he says if lack of
honor
is something evil is something bad
you cannot be an evil through the
instrumentality of some other person
any more than you can be in shame any
more than you can disgrace yourself
other people can't really disgrace you
it's only what you
do that makes you vulnerable to
that that emotional dynamic we could say
of of disgrace of feeling shame of
feeling guilt
so this is a very important reflection
isn't it
if lack of honor really is an evil from
a stoic perspective
lack of honor lack of external
acknowledgement by
other people lack of other people giving
us you know as we say warm fuzzies or
strokes or
whatever other parlance you want to put
put it in
these days that is not something that is
evil that
is something that is an indifferent from
the stoic perspective
but epictetus is writing uh and speaking
for people who aren't all the way there
who don't realize or
do realize but can't quite get
themselves to acknowledge
consistently that these things aren't in
in fact goods and evils
outside of ourselves that the good and
evil lies within ourselves
so lack of honor not being acknowledged
by
other people it's not really an evil but
if it was
then there would be a problem here you
cannot he says be an evil through the
instrumentality of some other person
it's only what you do it's only what you
choose
that really fundamentally affects
you so he goes on and he adds
think about this what is your business
what is your ear going what is your
function as
as we might say what's your job what's
your work and
we don't necessarily mean what you do
from nine to five to earn a living
because your job might be something like
being a parent or your job might be
something like
helping out in your community or it
could be
what you do in your career or your job
it might be a hybrid of all these things
but what is your function what is your
ergon is it your business to get office
to to be promoted to have authority over
other people whether it's in an
institution
or in local government or on the
internet to be the mayor of whatever
you know this is kind of a facetious
thing i don't know that people use
foursquare that much anymore but you
you get the idea is it your job to be a
thought leader to be an opinion former
to straighten everybody else out on
facebook about their political
views or their views on diet or their
views on this or views on that
no that's not really your job you might
have taken that on
as your job but in doing so you might
have actually made a commitment that you
can't possibly
fulfill and you probably should
reconsider that if you have and it's
okay
to reconsider those sorts of things so
is it your business to get office
no is it your business to be invited to
a dinner party one of the
favorite metaphors that epictetus has is
it your
is it your business to have people
invite you over and
you know here in the states you show up
with some flowers
or some beer or some wine or dessert or
whatever and you smile at the door and
you come in and make some nice chit chat
have the appetizers the amus
bushes you know if you have fancy
culinary friends
and then you know the main meal and talk
to people
we go on and on and on right dinner
parties um
those aren't really the the be at you
know the the the the
whole sum of life are they no unless
your job is to
put on dinner parties in which case that
would be the you know
your your job but that's not the job for
most of us that's sort of the icing on
the cake you want to make sure that the
cake
is actually there so he says certainly
not these aren't your job
how then can this be any longer a lack
of honor how can you be dishonored by
not being invited to
the dinner party down the street that
the
you know couple that just moved in is
having with their friends with the
people that they know it's
it's ridiculous to expect that you're
going to be invited to that
if you haven't put in the time in the
organization it's ridiculous to expect
that you're going to be
advanced up higher if you haven't put in
the time requisite as epictetus will
point out in other places
kissing up well then don't expect to get
pushed up in
in promotion so he says how can this
in fact be any sort of lack of honor
how is it that you will be nobody
anywhere
well the answer is this if you think
that
being somebody depends on other people
acknowledging you
and and we could you know use the
examples that he's got so far being
invited to a dinner party
being given some sort of promotion being
given some sort of public responsibility
we might add to this you know having an
online presence
having people give you thumbs up instead
of thumbs down uh
having people like your posts or or
retweet you
or whatever acknowledge you on follow
fridays
you know linkedin even has this function
where you can uh with complete strangers
who you're somehow connected up with you
could recommend them for
curriculum design or being a swell guy
or whatever it is
that you want if we think that
this is what honor really consists in
and that if we don't have honor we're
nobody anywhere we're going to be in
real trouble
we're going to feel bad we're going to
have all sorts of negative emotions
associated with that
and it's going to be a difficult dynamic
to get ourselves out of
so he says when you ought to be
somebody only in those things which are
under your control
whether you're somebody or not from the
stoic perspective does not depend
on whether people are going to hear you
talk or whether people are saying that
guy understands stoic philosophy so well
or whether they're signing up for your
classes or any of these sorts of things
it's how you manage your own life
how you manage your relationships how
you manage your thoughts
your emotions how it is to be quite
technical
that you use your faculty of choice that
is
totally up to you according to stoic
philosophy
that is where being somebody
resides and you choose whether you're
going to be somebody
or be nobody that's
that's something that is also within
your control
so he says in the things that are under
your control
you are privileged to be a person of the
very greatest honor
now here is in the greek where that
transition takes place between
talking about honor external honor timia
or time and being
axios being valuable being
worthy he says in in this
sentence right here um
uh here we go xst soy and i place to
axial so to be uh
you know have the greatest of value
because where fundamental value resides
for the stoics
is in our own personalities
in what we do with them and what we make
of them so that is something that you
can take with you
even if nobody's paying attention to you
even if nobody's replying to your emails
even if you walk down the street and
nobody recognizes you
or even smiles at you you
still are somebody and you can
be somebody you can be the greatest
somebody
provided you take the care
to do that for yourself to remind
yourself that
you have control over what truly matters
and that it's your opinion that counts
the most
it's your acknowledgement of yourself
this might require
some uh exercises in self-affirmation
which you know from a stoic perspective
would not be a bad thing so long as
they're based on
unreality he goes on and he brings up
two
other concerns that people have as sort
of rebuttals
that they would bring out so one of
these has to do with friends and we'll
look at that in just a moment
and the other has to do with one's
community
so what about friends
he says your friends will be without
assistance
epictetus responds well what do you mean
by being without assistance
and then people will say things like
this they will not have
paltry coin from you you will not make
them roman citizens and epictetus says
well
who said you were going to do any of
these things these are not
things that are fundamentally under our
control
so if that's what your friends think
friendship consists in
you you've got some friends that are
actually a bad influence on you or at
least not a good influence on you
if that's fundamentally what they're
worried about you might say the same
thing about a family affection as well
if your family is only interested in you
insofar as you're putting money on the
table
or opening up opportunities for you they
don't really care about you and you're
better off facing up to that fact
so he says um who said these are some of
the things
under our control and not things which
others do and who is able to give
another what he does not himself
have so what can i give
my friends well you know people invite
me to places because they want to talk
philosophy
sometimes they want to pick my brain
about some some business matters as well
because i know a little bit about that
but you know they're not going to bring
me along
because i am a beautiful model type
uh or because of my musical abilities
or or because of you know my my athletic
abilities at one time perhaps they might
have done that
but you know they're not going and
they're certainly not going to bring me
along because i'm going to make them
rich and famous or anything like that
or make them a roman citizen although
i do have to mention i get some weird
inquiries every once in a while
from people who think that somehow i
have some control in the academic sphere
when the reality is almost nobody in the
academic sphere
has any control over anything that
matters but that's a that's a whole
side note that we could do a whole
paragraph about
in any case the things that we do have
control over
are our personality our choices what it
is that we do with our
our time how we respond to other people
so you know what do you have control
over when it comes to your friends
whether you're a good listener or not
that that is up to you
whether or not you uh think about your
friends problems and
give them honest uh good advice
that that's based in some sort of
understanding of the situation
that is up to you whether you you give
them a lot of money or buy them fancy
clothes
or or take them to restaurants and
always pay for things
okay that is up to you if you have those
resources but that's not going to make
you friends with them
in any sort of lasting important way
and then now notice what the friend says
um get money then says some friend in
order that we too may have it
and epictetus says okay that's an
interesting proposal
you know uh and we could say this about
other resources as well
get in shape you know you know make this
contact for me
make this introduction and epictetus
says that's fine
there's nothing that says that i can't
do that but i have to think about this
am i able to do that action and yet at
the same time preserve my own integrity
because sometimes i can't do both
if your friend is asking you to do
something dishonorable
shameful they're not really a friend
this is something that happens a lot in
life people
are manipulated people are turned out
people are reduced to
mere objects that get other objects
for other people objects of their
desires this happens a lot
and we live in a culture that tries to
turn us in certain respects
into you know
you might say sites of replication if we
want to be kind of fancy about this
if you think about advertising right
advertising now doesn't just
uh tell you about the product and give
you a hard sell pitch you know buy it
now
it tries to tell you a story tries to
get you involved tries to get you to
to you know think it's a cool thing that
you should put pitch to your friends
um very brilliant marketing technique
but marketing and stoicism
in certain respects are antipodes from
each other
so he says if i can get money and at the
same time keep myself
self-respecting and faithful and
high-minded
show me the way and i will get it but if
you require me to lose the good things
that belong to me
in order that you may acquire the things
that are not good
you can see for yourself and notice what
he says here how
unfair and how inconsiderate you are
unfair on essos right unequal
um and then inconsiderate
uh agunomones not really thinking things
through
not really paying attention we have this
happen a lot a lot of the time you know
do this and i'll be friends with you do
this and all
care about you people offer us these
kinds of deals
that are not really good for us and
they're not even good for them
because what they're asking us to do is
supply them with something
that might actually be bad for them or
at least
you know probably as an indifferent it
doesn't have moral value
and they're asking us to sell something
that really is
morally valuable something that is axios
that we have in ourselves and to to get
rid of it for them
people do this uh in order to be uh
respected people do this out of motives
of
of love uh romantic love is is a
particularly dangerous
uh sort of situation in which this
occurs people test each other
will you do this for me will you do that
for me and if you have to give up your
self-respect in order to do it
epictetus says it's a bad bargain
so he says ask your friend then which do
you really prefer
do you prefer money or do you prefer a
faithful and self-respecting friend
because i can't give you both if you
expect the money from me
i can give you that but then i have to
quit being a
faithful and self-respecting friend we
might say the same thing in romantic
relationships
where there's some sort of coercion
brought about
do this for me it's often in terms of
sexual matters
but also in terms of like you need to
give up your friends and your family
the people that you care about break off
the relation with them right
that's a danger sign right there
somebody who wants you to do
that if you're almost your friends and
family are nuts right in which case you
do want to leave them behind
but that's irrespective of whether
you're involved with somebody
if they want that from you can say look
i can give you that
or i can give you me as a good person
but i can't give you both so which is it
going to be
and then if they tell you you know put
like that
well i i really do want the um the money
or i really do want the
uh you all to myself now you know
to to leave that relationship you're not
going to be to take the theme
to begin with you're not going to be
somebody with them
or the somebody that you are is only a
reflection of their
desires and fears it's not really the
somebody that you
are if you want to be somebody and not
nobody
you have to do it on your own grounds he
goes on
and he says help me therefore rather to
this end
do not require me to do those things
which will make me lose these qualities
that's a perfectly legitimate thing to
say to anybody who claims to care about
you
anybody who claims to feel affection
towards you anybody who claims to be a
family member
a friend a colleague you're expecting
them
in effect to recognize and behave with
integrity
so that they don't keep you from
behaving with integrity
and having integrity within your own
being depriving you of it
now he goes on and he treats the second
possible rebuttal
but my country my potress this is
my homeland notice he doesn't say my
polis
my political community my potress but
the place that i come from
my my roots you might say my country
says he
so far as lies in me will be without
assistance
won't have somebody coming to help it
out in important ways
we can say this not only about where we
grew up
or where we live we can say this about
the company we work for
we can say this about the educational
institution
that we are attending or
teaching in or graduated from people
feel a sense of attachment like that
that's why they pay for buildings right
it's not just to get their name on it
it's also to be benefactors
we can say this about all sorts of
things about
people who share our hobby or our
obsession
we can say this about online communities
it will be without assistance now he
asks
okay so what are you talking about what
kind of assistance do you mean
and now he's talking about you know an
actual homeland
but we can think about other things it's
not going to have uh
logias or baths of your providing these
these are like big
building projects right and he says okay
well what does that mean who
who cares about that and here's a great
example
that he uses neither does it have shoes
provided by the blacksmith nor arms
provided by the cobbler
blacksmith provides arms you know
weapons
horseshoes too and other things as well
who provides the shoes
the cobbler who provides the food the
grocer
who provides the massages the massage
therapist we can go on and on and on
right
each person has their task
is it the task of the blacksmith to
build a big
college up on the hill no it's his job
to sit there in front of the
hot you know forge and hammer things out
that other people can use
is it the farmer's job to inform us
about uh philosophy no i mean if he
happens to do that
or she happens to do that that's great
if you find some way to fuse
farming and philosophy together that's
really cool but that's not an
expectation for the benefit of your
homeland
right where you're from so he says if
you
uh is sufficient if each person fulfills
his own
proper function you might say it in a
more
contemporary way it's fine if everybody
sticks to their own job if everybody
does their one job well you've all seen
these uh funny memes
uh you had one job right and it'll show
you know something getting totally
screwed up
we have an example of that uh
contemporary example
uh which by the time you watch this will
no longer be contemporary but
uh i witnessed last night as i'm
shooting this this video
which is the uh game which was supposed
to kick
off the nfl season got screwed up and
cancelled
precisely because somebody painted the
field wrong with
a paint that could have produced player
injuries
you had one job paint the field
everybody's really really mad right
if we all stick to our job we make a
better environment for everybody else
you can say this not only about you know
economic transactions you can say this
about
how it works within a college you can
say this about how it works within a
company
you can say this about how it works
within a family
not everybody has to do the same thing
so he goes on and he says
if you secured for your country another
faithful and self-respecting citizen
would you not be doing it any good and
the person he's talking with says yeah i
guess so
very well and then you would also not be
useless to it
so think about this in terms of
political activism or all these other
types of activism that people do
we can change the world for the better
in many ways
and we do want our our homeland our our
patria
to be the best that it can be but does
that mean that we're
all individually responsible for all of
the
the problems no you can work on
this thing or this thing or this thing
and if you feel a calling to do that
if you know eliminating uh the horrors
of factory farming is your thing
great but don't expect that that means
that you have to do everything else or
that you're even the one person
who's gonna change the world in that
respect
you're probably going to make a little
bit of effort and that is enough
that is something that is not nothing
and you're not nobody for doing that you
are
somebody who chooses to to benefit their
their community
so he says uh the the person might say
what place then shall i have in the
states well
epictetus says whatever place you can
have
and at the same time notice the
trade-off here
and at the same time maintain the person
of fidelity
and self-respect that is in you
people come to politics all the time and
say i i want to change the system
i want to make things better there's a
lot of people
who have great intentions and then they
get into politics and politics is very
messy
requires a lot of compromises and
there's a lot of corruption
uh you know in our contemporary
democracies the way in which political
processes work
is um you know quite often dismaying to
to watch to find out about
and you're going to be constantly posed
with this this issue
there's getting things done getting you
know what people want
and then there's maintaining the person
of integrity
and faithfulness fide uh pistes inside
of you
the person that you brought there and
you're not actually going to be doing
people a hell of a lot of good
if you allow this person to become
corrupted because the whole point of you
going into politics to change the system
was that you were bringing
something new that had been lost by
these other people who came in also
with integrity and then somewhere along
the line lost it
we can say the same thing about any
institution that you enter
as you rise up through the ranks there
there are a lot of temptations
to get rid of that integrity because it
seems to stand in the way
so that you can advance from a stoic
perspective if you do that
you are actually going to be throwing
away what is more valuable
so he says if through your desire to
help the state
you lose these qualities what good
would you become to it when in the end
you turned out to be shameless
and unfaithful we can say the same thing
what good
does it does it do for you to rise and
become the ceo
of the corporation that is ruining the
environment for all of us
if along the way you quit caring about
the environment and the harm
that that company is doing it's not
going to do any good you're just
as we say only the faces change
so you have a choice if you want to be
somebody
you have to recognize that that
somebodiness comes from within you
it's not external honor that determines
it
it's not what other people think of you
that determines it although there's
nothing that says you can't take into
account
what they have to say if what they have
to say is just and prudent and
and you know uh comes from a good place
uh you know well informed we can pick
whatever qualities we want
it's not that you can't incorporate that
but you have to have something within
you
in order to be able to as we say make a
difference
and even if you don't feel like you're
making a difference from the stoic
perspective
if you're behaving with integrity if
you're behaving with justice
prudence courage and and temperance
you are in fact making a difference
[Music]
you